hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to west of loathing
I've recuperated from the horrors that I
experienced in the ghost town of eternal
perpetual paperwork but here we're gonna
carry on try to get to the bottom of the
mail situations that we can build this
bridge what is what a place is it
supposed to weigh station do you know
about mail
how do goblins communicate over long
distances poppin spores floating on
winds new goblin growing saying a
message that's [ __ ] gross
ah disgusting Postal Service property no
trespassing I'm a trespass ooh hello go
through let it arrive in all right go
thro blank pause guard go thumb reboot
he'll an article in here about how they
had to change the name of a nearby
cemetery due to so many skeletons being
raised there you marked down at
cemeteries location alright
newspaper someone removed all the funny
so there's literally no reason to care
about them you're goddamn right you are
this cabinet is full of maps but do you
have no idea what any of them mean maybe
you could ask about it at the low post
office in dirt water yeah maybe or maybe
not
I'll go the app baby alright what's over
here why is there an outhouse in here
you don't even know what know what
bureaucratic processes were involved in
the placement of the house was there an
inn outhouse where's it out in house out
the house house I have no money let's go
to reboot Hill and farm me up some money
please
oh you sends an extremely powerful
extremely malicious cow presence nearby
hellström ranch hell yeah I'm going to
hellström ranch how powerful we dog in
here whoa that is a rip in a dimension
oh wow Yanks what's up Gary weird
feelings a sensation of puzzling huh
from that direction coming West Pole oh
really the West Pole
ringing this will attract the attention
of at least one infernal cow it's a
portal to Hell you hear T Hobbit is
mooing this sure seems like a powerful
source of hell cow energy okay alright
the only part of this jug that didn't
burn was this horseshoe attached guess
it's really good luck I got a lucky
horseshoe good for me pistol attack
damage god damn it why was a nice snake
oiler oh I wish I was a snake oil that'd
be so much better than this on a shoot
things and people
I was fight at least one cow hello Gary
don't let him do that to you
okay Gary let him do that to you so I
don't deal with it what is that wait
wait Gary will blast all of your enemies
with spores reducing all their stats
that sounds horrifying okay Gary there
was no point to that all right Gary hit
him with your best shot Gary that's a
terrible shot Gary you're disappointing
me you're nothing but a disappointment
and frankly I don't love you anymore ow
BAM alright well I got that they're
super evil alright roasted calzone but
at least now I can get a better
lock-picking I could get better dicker
and eventually but no no sadly not now
all right what's in here
woo hello you lack the proper
leatherworking expertise to use these
tools Oh
shelves mostly burned burned leather
working manual am I about to get my kids
about to get I just got leather working
Oh
after you're done reading it you
understand that the book itself is bound
in valuable leather you tear the book so
you can make something else from it
alright alright make something out of
thick leather woo I can make by oh the
Hat I can make my own oh I could get a
meat bonus though I like a new hat oh
look at that
I'm gonna make something I'm gonna get
bag oh hell yeah oh I'm gonna make me
some pants oh look at those pants oh oh
ah yeah I'm gonna get lassos oh hell
yeah give me those pants
oh sorry kneeling pants you got to make
way for the better pants here oh look at
that hat ah oh not as good I don't like
it as good but it's got so much muscle I
gotta wear it it's good hat mmm it's
gonna grow on me alright maybe it's a
shitty hat it's a pretty bad hat it's a
it's a disgustingly bad ad I actually
don't like this hat at all don't like
that but I'm gonna the West Paul for
some reason for memoriam all right I'll
go there real quick and then I'll go to
the West Pole I'll be I'm not gonna stop
in here I got gonna continue on I keep
getting distracted by different things
that I'm not supposed to be go
oh I wander in Sally are you doing oh
yeah I really have anything good I don't
know why I stopped here actually I'm
gonna leave now okay I'm gonna leave I'm
gonna put on my black cap because I like
that hat better that look way better
than this and I'm more about aesthetic
than I have about functional purpose I
shout into Sally's face Oh bones whoa
the cairn cow what the [ __ ] is that I'm
gonna get beefy for that one [ __ ] dude
Miami well Bob y'all go Gary go oh good
I am hit you with a Bonilla stack of
Bones take some of that with you what
the [ __ ]
this yucca wants to be further east than
it is all right loco weed that's what
Tim Fleur would like but I can't do that
pile of weird rocks mess with him
alright they don't seem to weigh much
much as they should and they sort of
drawn to each other you could probably
make an interesting Karen out of them
something suave oh cool zig zag ooh
that's cool uh-huh that's nice something
powerful an impregnable whoa
I got a perk hard a stone your
circulatory system is partly stone now
which makes your blood even more thicker
than water than I thought that was a
penis above those straight up of penis
something mystical a mystical sigil ah
nice Megan another tower hmm that's good
it's something suave cool zigs it now
I'm gonna make well make some nice dome
ace some sassy face ah that's nice ass
that's a weird face that is goddamn
weird face that's goddamn weird face now
so special about it apart from the fact
that it isn't in pile all right pick it
up if it's way heavier than it looks you
can't budget at all weird
alrighty then what about what if I make
all these super manly Tower penises what
if I do that huh what if I do that no
not that there we go
all right god that how about that now
why is this happening
all right fine then I'm a making some
now I me threatening fist oh all right
fine there was no point in being here
I'm gonna go to reboot he'll cuz why not
well there is no a lot to occupy
yourself during these long rides if
you've seen one cloud that looks like a
duck you've seen them all be good
opportunity to uh sir sighs your upper
body but you don't I have a design bills
try to straighten the spare horseshoe
okay all right I'll do that you spent
some time grunting and puffing trying to
unbend a horseshoe with your bare hands
doesn't work but it's quite a workout
good for me I'm a musclehead I'm a
cowpuncher that's what I threw in that's
how I do it
Wow these trees hello such trees they
are for spooking yeah no kidding these
are great a scary trees I hope they not
my soul that's sucking out I don't
really know anything about gobbling
religious beliefs do you guys believe in
Souls yes but we sharing it's
complicated all right Gary you carry on
reboot hell don't worry it's just paint
not blood there's a keel and the trunk
of this tree
what's the key well it's not prompting
me so I'm assuming it's not there don't
know I've gone over there was a whole
lot nothing over here but I'll look out
for a key to goes to that tree
eventually hello Claude one see the
ghost of an elderly woman holding
flowers she seems lost and depressed
above and beyond what's expected for a
ghost howdy ma'am is there something I
can help you with oh it's awful I can't
remember I can't remember at all let's
start at the beginning okay well you see
I had four daughters they married four
brothers this Smith boys and after that
they have each five dollars of their own
unfortunately I allow live to every
single one of the 24 of them you uh you
know you're a ghost right oh yes in fact
I died here in this graveyard where
they're all buried I came to
them and I suppose my poor old heart
finally gave out that's not the problem
though 95 years is a pretty gun good run
after all so what did you forget I
brought this bouquet of flowers to put
on my favorite granddaughters grave but
I can't remember which of them was my
favorite I'm so ashamed that I can't
bear to leave until I remembered oh I
see well maybe I can help you figure it
out oh thank you I appreciate that
effort so much all right what do you
remember
first name ended in a vowel okay
anything else or when I was 40 she was
born now no 37 was it 42 must have been
somewhere in that range at least okay
all right
anything else first name was longer than
her last just like mine okay she wasn't
buried next standing my other daughters
anything else she sniffs a little she
passed the poor same age as poor poor
Becky who was always in such ill health
anything else
favorite hobby was knitting she knit me
a lovely sweater for Crimbo just the
year before she died that's all I can
remember
knitting okay then hang on let me think
a moment I think I know she was not I've
no goddamn idea how did I know oh jeez
Hey god be with you god damn it aah
Rebecca Smith could be her
no wait Rebecca Smith that's her okay so
in 1840 ish she was born not you wise
old this time the bar ate him let's dig
it up I got a marmot skid hat
oh oh god damn it if only I was a snake
oil salesman god this hats cool Peggy
immortal kind of ironic Big Bob
Hurlingham gone to the big pie eating
contests in the sky I got a tripe pie
gross I came too full if bunker Stan he
was a real butt face
was he now snidely krandalls worth sort
of like a Benjamin Button kind of thing
1800 to 17-under clean Willie Hanks
really gonna really is gonna hate this
burial thing and it's sent to bomb tried
to eat her way out of a bear all right
buck genes Lee nobody ever saw a man die
that way before whole gang buried in
here I'll bash you whoa whoa I don't
like this I'm gonna bulrush you don't to
Gore you Murph
oh that didn't work at all oh I'm gonna
die I'm dead I'm dead uh well I got
angry but I pass it I got so angry I
pass it's only day two Wow holy [ __ ] I
made it pretty far well time to get
myself pissed off I'm a red-bellied yeah
I'm so grumpy so grumbled jeez anything
interesting Oh
miniature piano what the hell what does
that do Hannah isn't playing it turn it
on so Mary so tinkly okay all right then
anything else in this spittoon anything
goes in there's no spittoon off to one
side of a trail you spot a cactus that
doesn't look like quite right
specifically it doesn't look right
because it has a goblin face as you get
closer you become pretty sure that it
actually is just a goblin and a cactus
outfit it gives you some annoying side
eyes and tries to wave you away but the
cactus arms are very mobile you know a
guy called cactus bill don't wait Gary
talked to this guy turning out goblin is
cactus Shepherd shepherd cactus heard
from predators defending do cacti have
predators other goblins mostly okay all
right that makes sense okay all right
sure all right Roy beans house of
justice and jelly beans don't know why
I'm here morning AB you lations
Morton morning ablutions flushed right
another goddamn thing yes to spittoon
nothing special about it investigate as
soon as you get near the spittoon you
can smell the overpoweringly sweet
stench it exudes nauseatingly sweet like
the rotting corpse of a dead gummy bear
look inside garish rainbow colors swirl
together in congealing psychedelic
madness is roy using jelly beans is
chewing tobacco yes yes of course he is
investigate further we're talking about
a ball of jellybeans that has been
sucked on half chewed and then spat into
a brass bucket do you seriously want to
put your hand in that swill of
artificial coloring and thickened saliva
it'll probably never be clean again go
for it look I'm serious
you're about to be permanently died your
hand with a swirling mishmash of all the
worst colors in the spectrum no have a
tattoo that looks as grocers stupid give
it to me well I tried into the spittoon
and fish around for a while eventually
you pull out a really disgusting pistol
and a really disgusting hand to shoot it
with
I got spittoon handily stained
Condon's of a nasty spittoon on the
bright side that hand will never suffer
anything worse than that ever again oh
that's awesome
it'll probably make to sound when you
shoot it yeah you you you you you PU boo
you whoa there's a single yellow jelly
bean in this case with the sign that
says Paraguay and murder be honey jelly
bean very rare what kind of lunatic
would pay six thousand meat for a single
jelly bean now this guy and that's for
sure I said no oh geez that's a good
pistol oh well there we go
ah it's a good pistol better than my
toilet pistol give with that god I wish
I was a snake salesman I wish I was a
snake oiler that'd be so cool
howdy there pilgrim names raw bean howdy
Roy my mum Fleur thumper ding what
aveer well when I first came to these
pots I was all about two things
dispensing justice and dispensing
jellybeans
I was the biggest name in bounty huntin
and candy selling anyone ever heard of
gosh what happened oh nothing
particularly tragic got old is all hung
up my pistol for good he points to the
wall he's pointing at an empty oak on
the wall over a spittoon I still sell
some jelly beans from time to time but
they're out of fashion this whole place
is just a jelly bean museum now alright
found a letter addressed to you let it
give it to him he opens it snorts
derisively and tosses it into the
fireplace behind him thanks anyway for a
jellybean Museum I sure don't see many
jelly beans huh
bunch of crooks and shady character
stole them all three jobs suppose they
think I'm a soft target now that I'm
retired I'll be giving back well now I
certainly appreciate the assistance
can't offer much in the way of reward
but I can tell you which way the group
of thieves went if you happen out in
that direction jellybean thieves hideout
okay I'll go get them
alright not for sale this lack of
jellybeans is not for sale funny funny
funny funny funny funny funny hello Gary
Oh a place for going Goering is thinking
of one really what's that a cactus a
biggest cactus ever seeing with goblins
inside you discover a map location old
grandad well that does sound interesting
and or weird all right well yeah okay
alright got that thank you thank you
very much thank you very much alright
well might as well go to the jelly bean
thief's side huh oh no madness small
mind I'll go there but I'm not gonna
stay there I like the idea of madness ma
mine boo okay I'm not gonna [ __ ] it out
here holy [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] out of here
ah I'm attack you woo hey I will show
you with my stupid pistol bang oh it's
good damage that's good damage hi-yah
indeed BAM [ __ ] shall we [ __ ] alright
hey are you jellybeans bastards yeah you
approached the bandits seated around the
5 I mean this looking one speaks up
don't know who you think you are
stranger oh you better turn yourself
right around head back the way he came
lesson you want he led that's not very
neighborly
good God neighbor you fella soldier
jelly beans from an old man and I am to
have them back alright just how you plan
on doing that with craziness hey wait
can i hey I want to get intimidating
five that's amazing
Oh a thousand a thousand XP alright I'll
be back I'm gonna go on a farming
adventure the likes of which you never
seen before
argh assured lose man in a tight
stretchy pants charges at you out of
nowhere no more no more mushrooms yogurt
no more exploring my inner consciousness
while running in place I want to kill
something kill it and eat it
holy jeez you put on your anger his face
and puff up your muscles to look real
imposing hold it right there you it
isn't working he's still charging at you
take the head this guy stops pretty
badly fortunately he's too crazy
actually stopping eat you like you said
he runs off into the forest you gain the
effect angry ah damn it god damn it ah
[ __ ] of duhkham me [ __ ] a duck Oh me all
right [ __ ] it fine I'm just going to the
thieves I don't have intimidating fire
wanna take too long I'm too lazy god
damn it I'll fix it later
wow I'm crazy uh with words
listen fellas you stole a jar of candy
from an old man blah blah blah blah blah
blah boring blah blah blah blah blah I'm
crazy
the bandits hang their heads shamefully
and shuffle away that's right you
[ __ ] better walk away over a filthy
bed roll
all right missing beans grab them meager
food supply sarsaparilla
oh wait I need to turn off that goddamn
little miniature piano wait would you
like to turn it off sure there we go
that's better Jesus ill-gotten Goods ah
nice pretty nice bedroll must have
stolen it open it alright dude
like that little gun Goods needle cheap
whiskey meat all right I'll take it
I seem to be sure to meet these days
Yipes hey buddy
a guy your beans back I got your beans
Roy Bean who open that up all right good
I got some goodies here neighs all right
hey Roy Roy Oh buddy I got your beans
all right
the second jar jelly beans was stolen by
a passel of them weird goblin fellas
couldn't understand a word they were
saying but they were very insistent
there they go Northwest old that huge
old cactus folks call old granddad all
righty then well that's where Gary wined
me to go anyway got buffalo pile don't
want to go there I gotta go where I'm
headed
be there in a bit whoa look at the size
of that thing
Gary whoa Oh looking old granddad what
your granddad where no no the name of
the really big cactus over there a
famous goblin place named old granddad
but goblins aren't related to cactus an
honorary title I see well all right
let's check it out oh my god oh [ __ ]
god damn it every part of this place is
awful Hey hi no climbing for a human all
right talk to them I'm here for taking
back a jar of jellybeans you goblins
stealing Oh what jellybeans little
colourful sugar things all little fruit
rocks
yeah those those are for the pile the
what anyway no upstairs for humans maybe
we can trading no trading but you can
bribing me okay cool what are you
wanting a candy bar a good human candy
bar of the bubbles having you know what
it
you mean this oh yes wonderful thanking
you can i climbing now sure thanks all
righty then hello ouch ow ouch pile of
goblin junk there's a gash in the wall
of the cactus here revealing a vein of
sticky purple goo gross gross another
goblin no climbing okay can i bribe you
all right cactus here but delicious vein
in the other room but having losing my
tap all right I don't have a tap where
do I get a tap in the Goblin pile oh man
if I was a guy
damn snake oiler ah Frick I'd be able to
deal with that god damn it good job at
the gym it ah how am I gonna get enough
mystic allottee out of that Oh Frick it
dick I can't even finish this because I
don't have enough misuk ality and
finally I was a snake oiler God why
didn't I pick snake oiler
I wanted to Oh cow punching there's a
boring piece of [ __ ] profession I'm just
waving a bone all day I ain't got no
brains no smarts no nothing oh yeah
we're carrying on no I'd be crazy of me
to go back and start the whole goddamn
game over again and become a snake oiler
that'd be insane
hey it's educational and entertaining
one and only betting cemetery the five
hundred me for a lifetime pass pending
cemetery that's why the ride we ride
variety of guaranteed genuine animal
skeletons and you're free to touch them
to your heart's content well with your
hands that is no riding can I feed them
you can try neat interest alright let's
do it
oh why should i dickered my way down
there was an option for it if I had
moxie ah damn it
you're welcome whatever fine hello a
petting cemetery meet what is well I'm
not sure probably a collection of animal
skeletons creepy
no thank you all right suit yourself
then young grateful goof y'all go my own
way
whoa all right whoo all right skeleton
of a jackrabbit in a pinch the
Jackrabbit can help you change a wheel
on your wagon huh hmm skeleton of a
desert tortoise it is currently in a
very slightly less of a hurry to get
places than when it was alive plaque
says buffalo skeleton but there's
nothing here your Buffalo to buy this
fact there's an owl skeleton if you want
to know how many fireballs of digs to
get to the center of an enemy skeleton
just askin I'll take a picture put the
click of the flash you take a photo of
Hobart boo Burt alright spell damage for
the rest of the day that'd be nice
there's a bobcat skeleton Bobcats are
known for the ferocity and the weird
high-pitched noises they make when
telling jokes
pretty good hawk skeleton Hawk resents
being mistaken for Falcons and will
shoot you if you do it too many times
okay then we alright I got boon of the
Bobcat oh whoa Boone is a bobcat baby oh
yeah what does the owl normally do when
I'm not taking a picture of it yeah
whatever
probably spell damage I think it was
anyway whatever I got that so I can take
that back to the dude I'm all out of
money of course that's great to know
see if I it was it bread would write
bread would yeah bread would Templar
suddenly gets spooked by something off
the trail it's easier to understand why
there's a horse skeleton in the ditch
which is a bralette thing that's
probably extra spooky of your horse
merging the horse more closely you see
the tattered remains of a Pony Express
saddlebag in the skeletal flanks
starboard bags empty but the poor one
contains a skeleton hand with a ring on
it you include that either the horse
rider died with his hand in the
saddlebag or someone who's really sad
that the skeleton hand they ordered
never showed up even though they paid
for an extra two haven't sent Pony
Express
either way free ring Oh reduces the
frequency of random encounters oh well
why would they want that I love random
encounters they're good people those
guys alright let's see what we got here
hey dude I got it got the thing here you
go
great ah will you look at that what a
beaut well thank you mum Fleur I ain't
got anything for a reward but I imagine
you'll get some experience points out
yeah you know yeah that's me that's me
buddy boo it's me buddy put dents key
hey I could well I could open this now
got Holloway's pen that's pretty good it
goes on your lapel holy [ __ ] that's real
good what else I got oh I got my
revolting brutes though I don't wanna
mess with that that's that's like my
prized possession I think anyway so
anyway that is all for this episode
thank you everybody so much for watching
in the next episode I may or may not
have turned myself into a snake oiler
because I've just got Amy's been talking
about this game Amy loves this game and
she's been telling me about how fun is
snake oiler is
playing and cowpuncher while it's good
don't have quite the same pizzazz as a
snake oiler so maybe we'll see let me
know the goblets below so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]